هل استخدام تشات جي بي تي في المدارس يشجع
على الغش ام هو شكل جديد من اشكال التعلم
خمس مدارس ثانويه في الدنمارك ترى فيه
فرصه بدلا من كونه خطرا وبدات هذه المدارس
مشروعا لاستخدام تات جي بي تي في الفصول
الدراسيه يستمر لمده
عامين اذا تمكنا من تغيير الطريقه التي
يستخدمون بها فسنكون قد نجحنا في منح
الطلاب اداه جديده للتعلم ولكن ايضا سيعزز
ذلك العلاقه معهم ويغير فكره ان من المحرم
عليهم الحديث معنا بشان هذه البرامج
الطلاب ليسوا غرباء على روبوتات الدردشه
بما فيها تشات جي بي تي ولكن هل سينجذب
بعضهم الى اعتبار النص الالي الذي يشبه
النص البشري بمثابه جهد خاص بهم
وكيف سيقيم المعلمون الامر اسئله جديده
ومختلفه يثيرها انتشار روبوتات الدردشه في
ظل حرص الاكاديميين على التاكد من ان
الطلاب لا يمكنهم الحصول على الاجابه
الصحيحه فحسب بل يستطيعون فهم كيفيه
القيام
بواجباتهم يرى بعضهم ان تشات جي بي تي هو
اداه تشبه في عملها محركات البحث ويبدو
اخرون اقل قلقا فيقولون ان بعض الطلاب
وجدوا دائما طرقا للغش وتشات جي بي تي
ليست سوى الخيار الاحدث فيما يطلب بعض
الاساتذه من الطلاب اظهار تاريخ التحرير
والمسودات
وادله لاثبات جهدهم في المهام الموكله
اليهم في بريطانيا على سبيل المثال وبعد
ازدياد المخاوف من ان هذه التقنيه تسهم في
تحقيق تقييمات لا تعكس بالضروره مستوى
الطلاب الدراسي الحقيقي اصدرت مجالس
الامتحانات مجموعه تعليمات للحيلوله دون
استخدام الطلاب لتشاد جي بي تي في الغش
اما في الولايات المتحده وبعد حظر استخدام
هذه المنصه في البدايه اكدت وزاره التعليم
في مدينه نيويورك اخيرا خططها لتكون رائده
عالميا في جلب الذكاء الاصطناعي التول
الى الفصول الدراسيه وفي ظل اعتماد نسبه
كبرى من الطلاب على تشات جي بي تي يصر عدد
كبير من المدارس والجامعات في العالم على
منع استخدامه بشكل كلي ليعتمد الطلاب على
انفسهم لكن ذلك يوقعهم ربما في فخ اقامه
حواجز بين الجيل الجديد وتقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي بينما ترى مؤسسات تعليميه اخرى
انه بدلا من حظر هذه البرامج يجدر نشر
الوعي بين الطلاب لاستخدامها بشكل
صحيح